hier vous m'avez carrément fait pleurer
au téléphone on sait parler et je lui
dis est-ce que tu peux me redire tout ça
en vrai mais il m'a dit bien sûr j'ai
jamais menti
à quel âge vous avez à quel âge vous
avez rencontré euh
17 ans 16 17 ans 16 17 ans et c'est quoi
comment voulez-vous rencontrer j'étais
avec Jean-Jacques Debout ouais et
Jean-Jacques un soir parce que j'étais
très proche de Jean-Jacques et de
Chantal j'ai vécu chez eux quelques
temps et avant d'être connu et
Jean-Jacques un jour me dit écoute
demain on va voir Charles Trenet chantal
est fatigué
il est mort
et il me dit mais non il est pas mort
d'ailleurs tu vas le voir demain soir et
Jacques Pessis avec Vincent Perrot nous
amène à Rungis il y avait 70 ans vous
avez 72 73 Charles Trenet à Rungis c'est
une blague
et il était là effectivement et on a eu
un coup de foudre enfin ça a été
Jean-Jacques Debout m'appelait le mime
parlant je parle beaucoup avec les mains
alors coup de foudre et pourquoi on
avance un peu il vous invite à passer
quelques jours chez vous sur les bords
de Marne
chez moi
et puis là ça se passe tellement bien
qu'il me dit mais tu fais quoi demain tu
veux pas venir avec moi on va on va à
Nice etc bah je dis moi je veux bien
c'est presque les vacances j'appelle mon
père je suis papa il y a Charles Trenet
qui m'invite à passer quelques jours
avec lui on va on rappelle que vous avez
16 17 ans votre père il dit c'est cool
et papa voilà et papa me dit mais écoute
vas-y et qui est là-bas
tout l'été tous les thés avec lui
ses vêtements parce qu'on avait la même
taille et d'ailleurs souvent on allait
faire les courses à joint et il fait il
faisait passer pour son fils il me
faisait dépêche-toi moi mon chéri parce
que maman nous attend oui oui papa il
faut qu'on se dépêche alors on sait que
c'était un génie bien sûr et que c'est
une autre époque et qu'on a juge pas
encore une fois je déteste jugé c'était
une autre époque et je vous ai posé la
question au téléphone vous m'avez
répondu très honnêtement j'ai est-ce que
vous avez couché ensemble on n'a jamais
couché ensemble et on a une on a une
liaison on a essayé une fois voilà vous
avez essayé on a essayé et au bout de 10
minutes 5 minutes on s'est mis à rire et
on s'est pris dans les bras et on s'est
embrassé il me dit tu comprends j'aurais
tellement l'impression de faire un
inceste j'ai l'impression de coucher
avec moi-même mais vous vous m'avez dit
j'étais amoureux de lui sincèrement mais
si je suis très honnête j'avais 20 ans
et je couchais avec un monsieur de 70
j'avais envie de coucher avec des gens
de mon âge j'étais amoureux mais
physiquement sexuellement j'arrivais pas
et non c'est compliqué et puis Charles
Charles avait aussi il aimait bien tout
ce qui était les garçons est faible
musclé etc il aimait les belles choses
et et on était tellement proche avec
Charles on avait une sorte de fusion il
considère un peu comme son fils
j'étais un peu son petit frère j'ai des
courriers quand ils m'ont voient quand
je t'ai fait mon service il vous amener
quelques petites choses de chat j'ai
fait mon service sur l'agenda qui m'a
alors le pacha il va y recevoir la
culture quand tu as 22 ans le biltibles
commençait à avoir la trouille des
cachets du ministère de la culture des
lettres manuscrites de chaque planète et
c'est c'est vrai que d'ailleurs et même
une lettre où il parle de Line Renaud en
disant qu'elle me trouve méchant déjà à
l'époque tu vois c'est vraiment il était
visionnaire c'est merveilleux mais ce
que j'aimerais savoir c'est ce que
j'aimerais savoir c'est c'est bon
effectivement donc était l'homme de ma
vie c'est l'homme de mai vous étiez
amoureux mais sexuellement ça marchait
pas mais après vous avez été très
honnête vous m'avez dit il aimait
l'argent il aimait la boisson il aimait
l'argent au point de faire collection de
ce qu'on appelle des Pascal à l'époque
c'est des billets de 500 francs ça
serait des billets de 100 € aujourd'hui
et il me dit tu m'as dit oui bah ils
m'ont donné plein et puis il va
t'habiller j'ai acheté des montres des
fringues tout ça là il me donnait de
temps à autre parce que il avait il
avait au dessus de son frigo il avait un
attaché-case et un jour il me dit viens
je vais te montrer toi tu collectionnes
Napoléon moi je collectionne les Pascal
donc ils viennent 100 euros je pense à
Pascal souvent parce que il était copain
jaune et qui bouge voilà il m'ouvre son
pas et je vois oh il y en a beaucoup tu
es un grand collectionneur je lui dis
oui je vais t'en donner un mais tu le
gardes tu vas faire des enfants comme ça
des petits d'accord Charles avec ça et
de temps à autre il me donnait à Pascal
voilà c'est comment il était parce que
toi tu as une personnalité très très
excentrique on te voit quand tu arrives
quand tu es habillé mais lui aussi donc
quelque part il y avait deux stars et
vivre dans l'ombre de ce type comme il
était dans la vie ici Charles
aujourd'hui les gens Chalon sont ici
Chalençon on peut pas plaire à tout le
monde mais je m'en branle comme ça et
c'est vrai que quand on est qu'on a 16
ou 17 ans et qu'on fréquente Charles
Aznavour Fred mais là euh
Françoise François Mitterrand moi j'ai
fréquenté
[Musique]
c'est vrai que ça donne ça ça forme
quelqu'un mais Charles moi avec moi il
est toujours on sait jamais tu me posais
la question si on s'était engueuler je
me suis jamais engueulé avec Charles
Charles c'est la gentillesse non non là
où je te dis peut-être toi pour vivre
avec et ça se voit j'ai beaucoup de
producteurs qui ont travaillé avec il
était traités des valises d'argent il
était colérique et il était très
difficile
il avait alors les enfants tu m'as dit
au téléphone
je vais vous raconter une histoire il y
a quelques années on va un jour comme ça
au Fouquet s'il il y avait je sais plus
qui avait Gilbert Ozon son producteur on
était 400 et généralement je j'adore le
vin donc je choisis le mec d'hôtel vient
me voir il me dit Pierre-Jean je joue
qu'est-ce qu'on boit on prend
aujourd'hui et puis j'ai du Mouton
Rothschild 75 en promotion très bien je
sais bien que c'est bien le bouton et
j'ai pas encore prendre une bouteille et
puis Charles Aznavour mais c'est
merveilleux mais c'est merveilleux c'est
bon non et on commence à boire une
bouteille puis de bouteilles et à la fin
avec Charles on est arrivé à deux heures
on finit à 22h 23h Bon et Charles de
payer jamais il a on lui disait vous
envoyer la facture et on paiera plus
tard par retour par chèque une semaine
après George le secrétaire de Charles
m'appelle il dit mon dieu mais qu'est-ce
que tu as fait Charles vient de recevoir
la note du Fouquet si on a pour 80 000
francs 12000 euros
de 50000 euros aujourd'hui
le maître d'hôtel a dit que c'était en
promotion j'ai pas j'ai pas demandé le
prix moi oh puis après je me suis dit
écoute Charlie il avait beaucoup
beaucoup de sous sur son compte il va
quand même alors j'ai été puni pendant
15 jours j'avais plus le droit de
choisir le chéri alors ce qui est
étonnant et là où j'aimerais vous dire
il a invité 10 15 personnes à table là
où je raconte dans sa vie privée où il
était il faisait il était il était pas
là où j'aimerais qu'on parle de toi en
bien parce que ça m'agace on a juste
souvent entendu ça Lançon c'était le
michto de Charles Trenet je vais vous
dire quelque chose Charles Trenet c'est
son chauffeur qui est hérité de tout et
tu m'as dit que toi un jour il m'a dit
j'en ai marre de mon chauffeur c'est toi
qui va le devenir et donc c'est toi qui
aurait dû hériter c'est vrai ça oui
Charles avait c'était engueulé avec son
chauffeur avec son secrétaire c'est pas
parce que c'était son secrétaire Georges
que j'adore aussi qui est de Kanami et
il s'était engueulé et genre j'ai voulu
partir et il m'a dit écoute tu vas le
remplacer etc je dis écoute Charles je
suis ton ami je ne travaille jamais pour
toi moi j'ai 22 ans et j'ai et donc j'ai
rabibé avec Georges histoire avec
François fleurs
et ça s'est passé comme ça mais si
j'avais eu cette cette malhonnêteté
intellectuelle j'aurais pu très bien et
devenir le chauffeur j'ai jamais et donc
hérité et donc hérité bah oui mais mais
mais mais ce qui est étonnant pourquoi
pourquoi je vois qu'à la Garfield qui
met 30 % 30 % pourquoi c'est eu cette
tel amour tu n'as hérité de rien il t'a
même pas laissé une montre ou un billet
Georges nous a donné quelques petits
présentes comme ça et il a été bon voilà
mais Charles pensait qu'après sa mort
c'était un peu comme Rosa crédit tu
comprends après l'huile après moi le
déluge il pensait que George va le son
héritier prendrait soin de ses amis etc
ce qui malheureusement c'est pas c'est
pas arrivé et le pauvre garçon a été
escroqué par une histoire et vous êtes
au courant de tout planté d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui on parle quasiment plus de
Charles Trenet de tout ça c'est terrible
mais c'est vrai à l'époque moi j'avais
demandé à Charles je lui avais dit
j'étais trop jeune j'avais 25 ans 26 ans
mais ça prouve quand même tu vois qu'on
arrête de dire michto j'ai dit à Charles
va voir Dominique Strauss-Kahn qui était
mise des finances il y avait Élisabeth
Clément qui était l'avocat de Charles à
l'époque ils sont allés voir
avait dit à Charles Charles il faut
absolument que vous fassiez une
fondation mais il faut donner 5 millions
de francs c'était bien lui c'était trop
scan
ner je ne donnerai rien alors moi je
suis la bienvenue
[Musique]
attention oui excuse-moi Benoît question
je t'en prie j'arrive pas à m'arrêter de
penser que vous avez eu la vie de
Liberace ce fameux film ah oui
narcissique de chanteur qui reprochait
tous sur son jeune effet et c'était un
peu il voulait devenir dans le film
d'ailleurs il devient chauffeur
maintenant de Liberace et je pense qu'il
y a un peu une certaine forme de
perversion narcissique du prolongement
de l'enfant qu'il n'est plus qui voyait
en vous mais Benoît il a une
merci de me dire ça parce que c'est fou
ce que Charles c'est reporté sur
beaucoup de choses
qui nous a lié beaucoup avec Charles
c'était que mes parents étaient divorcés
et lui ses parents à cette divorcés dans
les années 20 c'était très tôt à
l'époque et l'autre enfin maman pourra
te le dire bien sûr et voilà tu connais
que tu appelles ta mère demain comme
Daniel tu vois elle est célibataire
moi je suis pas ta mère et Charles ça la
fixation de Charles c'était toujours de
remettre mon père avec maman pour qu'il
se passe alors j'ai une dernière
question très vite parce que je suis
content de Daniel le dernier saut tu es
tu étais le dernier le tenir la main
lorsqu'il est mort à l'hôpital à cause
de l'alcool il buvait beaucoup qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce que vous êtes dit ça
direct à te demander on s'est rien dit
parce que le pauvre on devait déjeuner
avec Jean-Jacques Debout et Chantal Goya
le samedi il cette attaque cérébrale il
a été envoyé directement à l'hôpital
Henri Mondor et je suis allé voir
Charles le dimanche et quand je suis
arrivé il était dans le Coran
il était beau et enfin il était repose
etc je lui ai pris la main assez
impressionnant je lui ai pris la main et
voilà et puis je lui ai dit que je
l'aimais et c'est vrai qu'à ce moment-là
excusez-moi
parce que j'aimais tellement c'est top
et je me suis dit Charles je n'ai pas
peur de mourir et nous nous reverrons un
jour ou l'autre voilà tu sais pourquoi
je t'aime beaucoup parce que ça me fait
pleurer moi aussi quand j'entends tous
ces cons qui dit c'est un michto et
Machin il a pas pris un euro c'était
vraiment amoureux tu l'admire quand tu
me parles de lui tu as des tu es émue je
suis de content la vérité